a one two three  [Music]  sleigh bells rings  in the lane  a beautiful sign  happy tonight  [Music]  is the blue bird  here to stay  is a new bird  sings A Love Song  We Roll Along  walk in the winter wonderland  [Music]  pretending that he is Parson Brown  he'll say are you married we'll say no  man  when you can do the job  later on  we've conspired  as we dream  by the fire  face on afraid those plans that we've  made  [Music]  Build a Snowman  pretending that he is Parsons Brown  he'll say I am married with  no matter we still find the time to fool  around oh later on  we'll conspire  as we dream  by the fire  the face on afraid the plans that we've  made  Wonderland  walk on the Wonderland  walk  [Music]  it's a hit  [Applause]